here in New York City lots of big
businesses thrive but little ones
struggle this is very difficult right
now for a small business is very
difficult
kamaal Salette who runs this store was
hit with thousands of dollars in fines
the first time we think is 2600 his
crime he sold three cigars for $8.00 89
cents 11 cents to cheap says New York
City his customers can't believe it
it's BS kind of stupid in the sense that
if somebody's willing to pay something
not in New York City here bureaucrats
say Tobacco must be sold for above a
minimum floor price why because anti
tobacco Crusader dr. Kerr trimethyl told
the Center for Disease Control very
cheap products should no longer be
available it deters children from
starting smoking you suggest this at the
CDC New York says ah good idea let's
also be considered very seriously in a
number of jurisdictions in California
why do you get to decide no I'm not
deciding I'm a person who studies these
policies I feel like the policymakers
lied why do the politicians get to
decide cigarettes are the most lethal
product ever introduced thanks to rib
whistles recommendation New York
cigarette smokers now must pay at least
$13 a pack people still have the ability
to buy it if they so choose just not
poor people we see much higher smoking
rates among poor people and so we need
policies that are gonna reduce tobacco
use among poor people I think it's
outrageous I mean first of all you're in
a poor neighborhood okay and number two
a lot of people smoke cigars are elderly
people seniors you know we're you to
charge $3 and more they choose it and
the right to make your own choices is
important people are still figuring out
ways to afford it it's not to the point
where no one who's poor is smoking do
you know that we have over 20
tobacco retailers for every McDonald's
in the u.s. it must be because people
want their what if you run a tobacco
store you're just screwing them I want
to see a transition toward thinking more
about healthy food and beverage because
that's gonna be a future making money at
the CDC reversal
defied that it should also be government
policy to reduce the number of tobacco
stores we're not interested in putting
stores out of business or making people
unemployed sounds like you are they're
gonna find new products to sell you're a
bully no I think the tobacco industry is
more of a bully when I say fork it over
you fork it over he referred us to this
ad from the FDA cigarettes are bullies
they are but New York smoking police are
worse they use the power of the state to
get their way and their tobacco rules go
on for 47 pages and this is just for
tobacco for food and refrigeration and
deliveries and everything else the New
York City Administrative Code could be
thousands of pages long lawyer and route
Ilham defends store owners who get fined
you get paid in groceries and pizza fish
and paper plates and tortillas the rules
mainly hurt little stores it's the big
guy who basically could hire lawyers the
big business community is thriving
you see Starbucks you see 7-eleven you
see Walmart you see target is the little
guy he was trying to you know pinches
pennies and make a dollar that has the
biggest problem
smoking hurts people the city says we're
just protecting people and I'm not a
smoking advocate but I think in this
country and in this city that people
have the right to do the wrong thing
they ought to we ought to but we can't
if the health police rule our lives
you